Transcriber: May Alkassir
المدقّق: Mujtaba Abdelwhab
welcome
For the first few years of my life
,maybe I was extremely introvert
,I always had a hard time
dealing with people
I always felt there was
.a big barrier between us
Also I always had troubles
,dealing with life in general
I always hoped everything would happen
.quickly without effort, even at first try
,Until, at that time in my life
I got to know Arabic calligraphy art
which was a safe area for me to
escape from
.any stress or tension in my life
At first, I started participating in
competitions in school and I won them
till I won in high school the first place
,at Alexandria level
then I decided to continue with
calligraphy, but I started to notice
that people look at calligraphy as just
.a hobby Even though it’s an art
And its rules are set almost
.1,000 years ago
That made me want to tell people that it’s
more than this and has more dimensions
to do that I had to start break the
,barrier between me and people
.also I had to get out my comfort zone
To start this step by step I tried to
begin a new journey and get out this zone
I started getting to know more activities
.and participating in more competitions
I really started a new journey and one of
the things I found out about calligraphy
is Typography which is simply a domain
,that integrates two arts
art of calligraphy and art
.of graphic design
it’s kind of digiliting calligraphy To
.make it compatible with the current time
Of course, we’ve all seen
computer typefaces
.So are logos in Arabic calligraphy
Among the domains I’ve discovered is
caligraphity, which is also an integrate
between two arts, the first one
is the calligraphy art
.and the other one is the graffiti art
The graffiti art that we all know
is the art of wall painting
This art is close to us because we often
.see it around us in streets and cities
One of the projects I saw that had
,a strong message
belongs to a Tunisian artist named Alseed
.In a neighborhood near the Moqatam
He tried to deliver his message by
writing it on more than 50 buildings
and to be able to see the whole message
.must go up to the Abbey in the Mountain
The great thing is this work won
.the UNESCO Prize in 2017
One of the domains where calligraphy is
starting to exist strongly is architecture
Of course we’ve seen many examples where
there’s calligraphy in mosques around us
.but it starting to break in recently
And when we saw that in a mosque built
,in a small village in Alsaed
Almasona village in Suhag and how much
,this line gave value to this small mosque
when this mosque started to participate in
competitions, it started to become famous
until it won the Stone award Prize for
.Architecture in 2019
The first time I got out my comfort zone
is in 2016 when I participated
in an exhibition in Tunisia this was a new
.experience which changed my life
To get out of the space where I always
,show my work
and to try to make people look at
.calligraphy in a different way
That made me know about lines
,in Tunisia for the first time
also it taught me that I must break the
,barrier between me and people
and I actually started to communicate with
.them flexibly and have the ability for it
Maybe anyone who’s doing a hobby
,is far from their field of study
,he’s always faced with this question
?could this hobby be his career or not
this question were always in my mind
because I studied civil engineering
which is totally far away
.from art and calligraphy
Of course there were another question
after I finish will I complete
?in engineering or calligraphy
I couldn’t be able to answer this question
until 2019 when I won Dewan prize
for Arabic calligraphy in Germany that’s
when my thinking started to change
because there’s starting to be a revenue
I can count on to go this way
maybe we all know how can scribbles
help us to be better in our life
this is what I noticed as I taught
calligraphy over a long period of time
that people generally feels better
.once they grab a pen and scribble
I noticed this with two of my close
friends, one of them was an engineer
He was always complaining to me
how much work in engineering
is putting psychological pressure
and big burden on him
.and It affects his life negatively
Of course, I advised him to start with
a hobby like calligraphy
Because it helped me before
.and I know it can somehow help him
And indeed, when he gradually
started to deal with calligraphy
and I asked him about his experience
He always said to me that he was starting
to feel that the pressure in him
was moving on to the paper and coming out
.of me, and I was thrilled by this result
My other friend was at point in his life
suffering from how he will complete
or find a way into his life and that he
needs to reorder his life and priorities
It’s been hard for him but by doing
the calligraphy he started to tell me
how he sees life in general as a phrase
at first he needs to sort the letters
to give him a word and then sort the words
to give him the phrase he wanted
and to be able to reach his target
.and see it clearly
calligraphy could have helped a lot of
people to be better in their lives
as well, it delivered a lot of messages
in the streets around us
and made a small village in Saeed
,becomes visible on the global map
.It’s also why I’m here with you today
There are people who give
their lives to art
but art gives lives to people
.streets and cities
.Thank you